[Music]
in Obama impostor news Obama pasta
impostor or in pasta posture but said
like slang oh I thought it was no pasta
I know David you really wanted it to me
like in fettuccine I was thinking about
an alphabet soup and those Obama
alphabets his face and he was saying
stuff like Amy how would this David
submitted by pancakes or french toast
dude french toast
yeah name-o between those two pancakes
all day best pancake in the best french
toast I'll still get the pancake but if
the french toast is made out of Hawaiian
bread I'm gonna have to side with that
I'm with you ginger have you heard that
a little hot cafe shout-out to you guys
that's where they have it Jordan Peele
used machine learning tools to create a
fake Obama that warns us about the
future I saw this machine learning to I
think that's dope
what do you did what do you what it what
is wasn't going I know I will show you
the video clip here we go be careful of
the future yeah not too far oh yeah here
we go we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point in time
even if they would never say those
things so for instance he could have me
say things like no kill monger was right
ben Carson is in the sunken place or how
about this simply President Trump is a
total and complete [ __ ] now you see I
would never say these things at least
not in a public address but someone else
would someone like Jordan Peele
oh I think this is a dangerous time for
you
moving forward we need to be more
vigilant with what we trust from the
internet it's time when we need to rely
on trusted new sources they sound basic
but how we move forward age of
information is gonna be the difference
between whether we survive or whether we
become some kind of fucked-up dystopia
thank you stay wolf [ __ ] dull like
the gamer community where the guys can
be like anime girls and they just like
is it like that it's kind of the same
technology I was used to make those deep
feet video I was almost convinced until
like I started paying attention to the
voice yeah yeah when I was paying
attention to the voice and I was like
yes not Obama well if you really pay
attention to the the image itself its
repeated motions and then the around the
mouth is a little weird yeah I noticed
how it's like that Obama did a really
good drawer and Peele impression yeah
that's pretty good
Obama is really good at it Jordan Peele
yeah thank you
yeah so last year the University of
Washington researchers used technology
similar to or like this exact technology
to take videos from things that former
President Barack Obama had said and then
generated fake videos of him like
spitting out those lines verbatim in a
machine generated type of format and so
that research team stopped just short of
putting words in his mouth like he they
actually like we've just rearranged the
weight like the words that he did say
but then Jordan Peele here and BuzzFeed
they they did this period this PSA
warning that there could be people out
there malicious people out there that
could soon generate
videos of just anyone saying anything
but and then eventually technology is
gonna get so good that it will have fake
words come out like something that
people have never said before they will
make them say crazy I can't even imagine
like it I know it's very religiously
people want to do bad [ __ ] all I want to
do is make Obama do a really dope back
rap rap battle yeah ER be style yeah
sorry talk is cheap yes it like for this
technology that we have available right
now that Jordan was using he still
needed to create the fake fake voice
yeah but eventually you could just
record Obama's voice and then create a
whole like yeah tamper with like
evidence in courtrooms and exact I was
thinking the exact same thing like how
do you prove that someone did or didn't
do something yeah like in the sci-fi
movies you know like if it's in the
hands of fat people imagine they hijack
the airwaves and then they they
impersonate the President or whatever
like everyone do this because it's like
some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't even
know if it's real don't believe nothing
that's the way I go yeah it's a dream
pew on BuzzFeed here they're just saying
like you know what we just need to be
careful where we get our information
from we need to not just blindly spread
whatever you hear and because these
things are now happening it was just
scary but I already knew not to trust
anything a lot of people are not like
you I know yeah it's just hard because I
even have like relatives who just like
to politely just we post and believe
everything and it's so [ __ ] dumb
because I'm trying to have a
conversation with them right and it
sucks too because like some of them all
over me and I have to tell them much no
no the worse cuz they're the most stupid
yeah they're [ __ ] dumb you would
think cuz because they just they don't
understand like technology and how it
works right so for example like with
Facebook and algorithms they're you're
only gonna get fed what you look into
and so I was explained to this jackass I
was like listen dude like you keep on
putting up this political [ __ ] right
I was like if I showed you my facebook
in California it would show you
everything that refutes what you're
doing so it's just it doesn't it's
nothing that these are facts and none of
these are like [ __ ] like specific
well proven facts it's all propaganda so
just find out your information for
yourself I was like for example like
he's super gung-ho about like whatever
politics that he knows about right
and I was like okay for these policies
do you actually know the policies are
you just telling me off of this article
he goes well art so you don't know the
[ __ ] policy if you haven't read it
don't say [ __ ] you know what I mean
and so but for him like he gets heated I
mean you could read it like that's what
these articles are meant to do it the
headlines are meant to trigger people
into outrage which is what I hate about
social media right now like are your the
Facebook outrage stuff outrage media
like that kind of stuff
because they essentially they just want
clicks that's why they do these click
big titles because they get more money
the more that you click on it so of
course they're gonna put something
that's gonna outrage you or that speaks
to like one side of people that's gonna
make them really mad because they all
click on in all share it and then that
website gets a bunch of money ad revenue
because you clicking on their webs their
webpage it's all money related like you
know Milo get innopolis he gets really
popular you know what I mean like that
guy just said a lot of stuff that's like
pseudo statistics even I mean and people
here are number they heard there were
statistics and they say back sure but
what is this that come from who where
the studies from like nobody [ __ ]
knows him and the steven crowder guy
does that to all the [ __ ] time they
just throw out random [ __ ] numbers
all the [ __ ] time and the people to
believe it but if you throw numbers
statistics out so official sounds legit
you make things sound so it's like yeah
well you could manipulate the [ __ ] out
of stats yeah yeah like Alex Jones to
like the far right wing dude he's like
constantly coming up with these
statistics and then they're being proven
wrong but they're like diehard followers
that listen to every single love Alex
Jones not fools batshit crazy he's
entertaining he is entertaining awesome
he's credible like yeah I mean there's
always gonna be people that follow crazy
you know it's it's product yeah there's
like oh yeah there's left-wing yeah like
like polls that come out let's say like
oh like like back in the election like
everyone thought Hillary was gonna win
because like the polls were like oh my
god crazy like 90% of America's vote
then it's like wish Hillary no way yeah
yeah no way Trump's gonna win yep it's
like and these are poles these are facts
these are statistics it's all like you
know but look what happened like is
there any news outlet that is unbiased
at all cuz every single news outlet is
owned by someone and as long as they
rely on money and ad revenue it's always
gonna be something that all yours the
public or makes them scared at the end
of the day it's it's entertainment it's
not information it's not unbiased I
think it's that the people that own the
media they want you to they want us to
fight because that's how they stay
employed because if they can come in and
say I can save you for they can be
create fear and then they go I could
save you from them yeah and then that's
how they get votes and that's how they
stay employed I don't understand how
people can't see that that all it is is
just making people angry in and really
like you wouldn't be angry at your
neighbor like you wouldn't if without
the news if you just got to know your
neighbor on like a person news is toxic
you wouldn't deal that way but because
the news paints whatever these people
out to be monsters whatever side you're
on it paints the other side is monsters
you don't even want to talk to your
neighbor because they now have a label
on them that makes them a monster and
that's when I [ __ ] hate about the
media that's why you gotta watch JK news
that's why you got away we make fun of
those [ __ ] and nothing you say
is fact cuz if you watch regular you
when you watch regular news you think
all police are black people killers and
you think all black people are like
murderers and [ __ ] and thieves and then
you think like all Asians eat dogs and
they do a really great job at making
everyone scared of each other yeah they
really do I want to go up to my neighbor
and ask for a cup of sugar not because I
need it I just saw a lot of white people
do it on TV they used to do right yeah
can I borrow a cup of sugar no wit Steve
grew up in the Midwest and on the East
Coast - and he said that that's what it
was like like in the suburbs that like
when you will like when you move in
everyone like brings you food and pie
[ __ ] BAM it was there was a grandma that
had two Great Danes and she had a girl
up in her backyard and when she moved
into my neighbor like to my neighbor's
house yeah she came to my house it gave
us a pie and my mom's like I don't trust
her cuz she girls marijuana in that
greenhouse ever just probably marijuana
in that pie and I was like I want to
[ __ ] eat it Plus why would she give
you free weed the whole sugar thing too
because it's like can I borrow a cup of
sugar so I know you lazy [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] store right there go get it
yourself
it is back in the day where you had to
wait for the farmers market or some kind
of [ __ ] lazy ho it's like right there
come on a cup of sugar is a lot like if
I have my sugar if I had three neighbors
come and ask me for having more sugar
get away from me my cup of sugar and
they did get to be a part of a
neighborhood watch and then look out the
window and call my neighbors and be like
do you see that lurker parked on the
street no the neighbor a personally I
don't know I download it when we lost
bricky and so I was like like look let's
stay in the know of what's going on and
then that was also in the people's
Amazon packages were getting stolen a
lot and out ham bro and then people were
backing each other up it's really cool
watch out there's this little that's
really good there's a cup black on our
corners coming in and then they were
like really help each other and then as
soon as that main thing was gone then it
became really petty again like what Oh
indeed I was septic one other one I
don't remember the petty ones but I did
remember one that one that made me laugh
cuz it sounded like a beginning of a
porno where there's this lady she
neither like her pipes fixed and then so
someone what she was like does anyone
know how to I figure I just just
immediately became sexual the way I was
reading it can anyone come over and fix
my pipes here a snake your drain
oh my come on in and then I was just in
one person but I'll just call a plumber
no no that's true that's so like
commonsensical and then she would write
back oh because I was just hoping
there's someone on my block and knows
how to unplug whatever and it just
became like a porno scripts
[Music]